today is the world day of the fight
against cancer
every year in europe and in the world there are
millions of people who are
faced with this disease
from personal experience or because
some canon is hit over
the last decades giant steps have been made
to  the prevention and
treatment of cancer today fortunately a
diagnosis of cancer is not a
definitive sentence but there are
effective tools to win this battle
in this world cancer day I want to
express all my closeness and
that of the group s d
to those who fought to those who are
fighting  and to those who fight this
battle aware of
European responsibilities in this area
the pandemic crisis has diverted
attention to the fight against cancer for too long
and yesterday with the presentation of the
european car assemble we were able to
relaunch this challenge
we are convinced that this is a first
step in the right direction but more can be
done and we will do it together  to all of
you